um
[Music]
[Music]
i am an artist i'm an activist i'm a
serious macaroni and cheese maker that
there's actually not a strong of
consensus about the relationship between
being overweight and being unhealthy
[Music]
all right turn me into see matthew
ready
oops
[Music]
well
we've had a chance to look over your
portfolio and it is safe to say
that we want you as part of our
corporate family son well i think it's
safe to say i want to be part of your
corporate family dad
we're prepared to offer you a six-figure
salary full dental and medical and you
can start right away that sounds amazing
um i was hoping you guys maybe had like
a retirement plan though like ira
oh uh
no well see the thing is is a lot of our
newer employees don't really stick
around as long as what we do offer is an
ica ica
uh it's uh it's an inevitable
cancellation agreement oh well
i can't get canceled i'm not a public
figure oh yes
that's what they all say
listen how long have you been on
facebook um since i don't know 2009. all
right well it says here you poked a girl
in your intro to biology class that was
a mistake my finger slipped that is a
microaggression buster brown
it's rape
rape
and it says here you also like dave
chappelle
it's a problematic association everybody
liked dave chappelle you don't have that
in context it's 2022 context is
irrelevant
i'll delete my social media
that's the spirit all right well you are
hired
oh
wait
wait a tick
it says here you didn't post a black
square on blackout tuesday
i was being beaten and robbed outside of
a bar
with a lead pipe
listen i'm the president of a fortune
500 company i can appreciate a
high-functioning alcoholic more than
anyone
but no square
i was in a coma
silence is violence
i'm afraid you're canceled
so that's it i'm i'm fired
i thought you wanted me to be a part of
the corporate family this place is like
olive garden
when you're here you're family and you
ain't here
no more
[Music]
jack it's danny
you owe me 200 big ones
yep i did it
i kept a newly hired white guy employed
for longer than
68 seconds in 2022
see on the course
you old so-and-so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
food
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
it smells in here in the studio a little
bit today really yeah it smells like
smells like fish in here i don't feel
fresh what is it
what is that some kind of sign
it smells like fish in you name that
movie line we started right off the bat
anyone who gets it you will get a lock
of gerald's neck hair
not head hair in that movie comment
below uh sorry we started a little late
today and that's because uh i don't know
if you saw zelinski the address that uh
just happened uh-huh he talked to our
congress yes yes he did yeah and uh
unlike we don't necessarily have the
49-hour turnaround that colbert had for
the elon musket which we'll get to but
uh we needed about an extra 15 minutes
you know well so a question of the
budget
nothing particularly new with zielinski
but i do want to talk about a couple
things today first off tom brady is also
trying out uh well not trying out he is
going to return to the nfl column
kaepernick is vying for a yet another
slavery tryout yes he wants to try out
for slavery yeah yeah he's been doing a
lot of kneeling gymnastics yes he has
he's been with the ribbon yes the sash
also he's one hell of a pummel horse a
champion yes i suppose i don't know he's
small enough i wish that i wanted
anything as badly as colin kaepernick
wants to be a slave yeah or black his
words i mean not to be blunt but all of
them he really works out that hair yes
he really does all right buddy there's a
there's a d perm in his
credit card history somewhere uh and
we'll also be talking about jon stewart
has this new show i guess on apple
they've been uploading uh content to
youtube and it constantly is thrust into
my feed
and it is this conversation that they
just had yesterday it was uploaded
yesterday is the single perfect single
most perfect crystallization of rich
white savior uh complexes that i've ever
seen on climate change and i want to
talk about that because i think a lot of
you out there maybe don't necessarily
know how to discuss with people uh
climate change and why the policy is
harmful not only to americans but to the
rest of the world so hopefully we'll
help arm you with that uh here today
also
more important than that if we are not
on youtube tomorrow dave will be filling
hosting for me as i go to change my mind
but there still is a show if we don't
let you know
that there's no show
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
if we're not here on youtube just head
on over to rumble there's a link in the
description or mug club lotteries credit
dot com club where we do an extra 45
minutes of show today we do uh pokemon
or racial slur
is that real yes
yes that's the game that's a real game
so there's the name that movie line and
then uh is tom brady the best
quarterback ever in the history of the
nfl i would like to i don't know
anything about sports but i just want to
hear your answers because it will make
gerald mad you can also beat him
he is here at g morgan jr how are you
sir i am doing
well-ish your inbox is going to be full
my friend it is uh holding up the sign
you guys were right yeah bad idea
hopefully not hold up a blank paper
not a good idea solidarity even you'd
have been better off doing it in russia
yes yeah i would have been like the
second lady that got arrested like just
take me to jail so i don't have to see
the memes yeah those police don't hurt
your feelings they just hurt your body
yes that'll heal they hurt your feelings
never go away and you also hear that
voice you know you love you can follow
him at landau dave dave landau oh boy
how about you good i'm fine i didn't
even answer it but ahoy good you
ahoy suffice it it's like uh dave landau
speak like aloha means both hello
goodbye
absolutely i want to raise good
[Laughter]
yes well that's okay well that's what
happened with the new west side story it
is
so i didn't watch it did you see it i
did it
is it just which makes me gay
i saw it in theaters i was one of the
nine box office tickets to west side
story yeah spielberg's gotta love that
box office return well i'm finished yep
that's it i'm done that's why i'm on his
mailing list he's like oh wow there was
only let's cross-reference who saw tin
tin in theaters with wes stephen kreider
wow who knew i saw tintin i saw tinted
yeah
it was really big in canada was it well
i mean the the comics oh okay yeah the
film the movie was not big anywhere no i
recall the film was not big anywhere
like look we perfected the facial
recognition like polar express no you
didn't
didn't even get close speaking of not
having perfected anything
uh stephen colbert
once again proved that you don't need to
be a perfect comedian or
passable
to garner a 15 million dollar salary
here's their sketch on the elon musk
tweet from
three days ago yes his tweet partially
in russian reads quote i hereby
challenge vladimir putin to single
combat stakes are ukraine
you have selected russia
round one
let us fight
winner takes ukraine
but you can still hear us we just poison
underwear poison underwear crazy tweet
crazy tweet voice on sushi
whatever this is
i have rubles i have dogecoin
they are both worthless
game over
we were by the way our mics were on that
whole time i'm not this is not me trying
to not laugh that's just here's the
thing
working in this uh industry um
i also understood that was 48 hours
after the elon musk tweeted what are
they doing this that that's not even
trending anymore what's because they
needed that amount of lead time to
create that sketch that animation and
they said yeah this is worth it also can
we record the voiceover on a graphic
calculator if i ever wrote anything like
that you send me to rehab yeah i don't
care how many times you say aloha you
are leaving buster brown i would fire
anyone yes i'd be like is this this is
what you find funny yeah because that's
a door i find that funny funny once you
get your things
look if you're going to do this sketch
and go back to and go back to this go to
mortal kombat and have elon musk ripping
out putin's heart at the end that would
be fun at least and some kind of justice
but they reference but they don't do
that
yeah stuff oh they reference coins
poison sushi poison sushi poison
underwear
and the photoshop is just oh wow the
animation yeah epic you can tell it's
just good well that's what 20-something
writers worth
and
how many editors and producers over
there and they have a budget of many
many tens of i know it's over 40 million
uh i don't think including colbert's
salary and this is the this is why
big tech has to acquiesce to these
people think about it how often do you
actually want to watch stephen colbert
look at the plays here on youtube right
now go look at stephen colbert look at
the place and you will see a discrepancy
same thing with trevor noah where you'll
see some videos or seth meyers a few
thousand plays maybe 100 000 plays and
then a few million plays because these
things get promoted and they
automatically show up in your suggested
feed and as someone who had to
experience
sorry again for the vox apocalypse
youtube created what's known as the
crowder rule for borderline i apologize
your fault it was a goof
uh
well nbc universal is what vox is and so
really the problem there was jimmy
fallon
and the same thing we've run into cbs is
it cbs uh
time warner this is cbs i don't know who
they're they're they're a conglomerate
with but the fact is
yes we constantly get uh copyright uh
struck from stephen colbert yeah no none
of this sketch that you're watching now
this entire episode will not be viewable
in japan because stephen colbert claims
it so youtube has to acquiesce to the
big boys because they have so much more
budget they have so many more hires and
they still can't that's the best they
could come up with well you don't want
your dirty secrets to get around no
well maybe well it's terrible you can
just leak it and you know then you just
all press is good press that is awful
yes that was so bad i truly thought that
was a joke like i didn't know it was a
real no that was a real sketch yeah no i
get it i and they aired it too they i
just don't uh
value life yeah anymore
well you mean your own life i mean
that's that's fine my own yeah you don't
need to hurt any you don't even take
anyone else out with you no that took
enough people out it's sucking my will
to live it's so bad i just don't
understand who pitches it and you go
yeah that's brilliant well here's the
thing if you're in that room and it's a
diversity seriously it's a diversity
hiring brigade right that's what's going
on yes are you going to say no to the
genderqueer biracial uh you know ricket
riddled man no you're like oh yeah
that's a good i that's a good idea of
course well you're probably gonna write
30 good ideas and then get to the one
that's not offensive at all and you're
like how about this one because all the
other stuff's going to get me fired
right you just look over to hr and
they're like
they're like yeah dogecoin is worthless
that's funny there's a war yeah
people are starving in russia because
their money's not it doesn't have any
value anymore can't purchase anything is
that funny should you put that in hey
also putin uh you poisoned someone i
don't even know that so really that was
the entire premise of this concept is uh
instead of hadouken it would be poison
underwear and i would like my uh
six-figure salary now more money please
it's underwear so it's funny yes yeah
that he throws back being tweets yes i
particularly like it when uh cartoon
characters uh act like people do in real
life yeah it's so funny i also love it i
also really like it when babies talk
like adults but that's just me i'm an
industry insider what happened so even
the audience is hating it that's what i
love you can hear the fake laughs and
then people just stop laughing yeah like
oh huh that's good i'm so glad i waited
in line in the freezing cold to watch
that and that's with a laugh sign that
guy has the hardest job in the world at
colbert he's like [ __ ] laugh he's
trying to figure out what a joke is he's
like i don't know i don't know
maybe this button holds up the laugh
sign when one of the producers is
talking about their son with leukemia
i don't know it's funnier than
funnier than
street fighter yeah
at least they use the right size i don't
want to hold the left side
usually helps when you write a premise
on a punch line it's just the worst i'd
like to take grace this stage speaking
of punchline i don't even know but
former vice president biden continues to
get press
and uh this is
from yesterday where former vice
president joe biden said that he has
the covid before one of his handlers
corrected him i had to double check this
to make sure he doesn't have kovit
correct no he does not that we know of
he could also have a cold who knows it
could also be dementia you never know
it's just guess that's why he just gets
irritated and starts arguing with the
radiator so that brings us to this week
in biden if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for me or trump then
you ain't black but there's been a
little change in the arrangement who's
on the stage because of the first lady's
husband
contracting covet but
look at this room and what you see
that's right
she's fine
it's me
the second lady the first gentleman
how about that if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump then you ain't black um by the way
it was also just so you know in case
you're trying to make sense of that and
i don't blame you it's almost impossible
kamala's husband yeah had kovid
kamala harris didn't by the way you know
who did kamala's husband's intern so
male intern oh that's interesting oh
geez he hasn't touched her in years
but him and brian like to take vacations
together okay that last part was not
true
brianna yeah it's different
how do you get covered in your well i
don't know how do you say that as
president and you don't realize that
you're saying that you have covent
that's a rhetorical question correct i
mean i'm not going to have to reach over
there and beat you with your own shoe
you know exactly why former vice
president joe biden doesn't know whether
he has covet or not i mean it just it's
so obvious but he's he's completely
capable of handling world issues that
we're facing right now i mean yes send
him send him to ukraine to solve these
problems you know what's sad that's the
quickest he's ever been yeah
yep somebody said it to him vladimir
putin could literally piss on his
forehead and convince him it's raining
april showers he's buying it
[Laughter]
totally totally fine most popular
american president in history well thank
god we have the safest and fairest uh
election in uh that's true in every
history of ever that i just like how the
world is now versus trump yes well at
least they respect us yeah listen that
means that matters he won one bellwether
county don't you take that away from if
there's nothing else about former vice
president joe biden look i mean i want
to give credit where it's due
he commands respect
so uh by the way
dave lando and i are uh on tour here uh
this year so you can go to lot of
credit.com two or four tickets may 14th
in tulsa oklahoma yeah baby god's
country and then uh june 18th we added a
show in colorado springs colorado the
tickets just went on sale because the
first one sold out so quickly we heard
you we added another one there you go so
you can go to the uh the page there okay
so i have the covid
no you don't
your first lady first lady's husband has
i thought he was referred to butt gig
after by the way he was right when he
said the first lady he just meant the
president
kamal harris ah
it's true
he's an idiot
well he's not an idiot he's just you
know old and sick someone needs to take
care of him yes someone needs to take
care of him not just in a home yes
exactly
cuomo said one up
yeah
he needs to he needs to go to the
hospice care cuomo whitmer and
associates yes there you go there's a
nice facility in detroit where the uh
the crips help run it yes exactly they
like to punch you that's your medicine
when you go exactly
but the good thing is after they punch
you they give you a little cup yeah well
no it's like you take three of these and
tell me in the morning it's like the tv
set when it gets fuzzy you just head it
until it works right his brain gets
fuzzy
plus also a former best friend button he
needs to be burped
then he's going to need bleed stop yes
gorilla glue so here's something this
happened this morning there's not a
whole lot there but uh you know zalinski
addressed congress today and he had some
requests slash demands from the united
states so
let's just address it right off the bat
remember pearl harbor
terrible morning of december 7 1941 when
your sky was black from the plains
attacking you
just remember
remember september the 11th
a terrible day in 20
2001 when he will try to turn your city
sounds like independent territories
in battlefields
is this a lot to ask for to create a
no-fly zone zone over ukraine to save
people is this too much to ask if this
is too much to ask
we offer an alternative you know
what kind of defense systems we need s
300 and other similar systems you know
how much depends on the battlefield on
the ability to use aircraft
if you're if it's not a rhetorical
question is it too much to ask the
answer is yes
it's all too much to ask is it too much
to ask for no by the way also i don't
one thing that we ask see this is your
offer
our counter i'm a lawyer that's what we
lawyers call a counter offer
is get one other shirt
yes that's true just one other shirt we
know you love that iron cross look and
we're like ah is it west coast choppers
is it white we have no idea but the
point is you don't need to keep us
guessing just change shirts and uh no
fly zone that's gonna be a hard pass and
send us more equipment this is one thing
too came in a package of six i just
wrote
[Laughter]
one almost for each day of the week
almost and uh
14 billion dollars in equipment that
we've sent them we're helping them yeah
do you know what his request would do he
asked the same thing from the uk and
boris johnson and he went and asked a
prime minister blackface i think
yesterday to british parliament or to a
canadian parliament canada can't send
them 14 billion dollars in right here no
but he said a no-fly zone do you know
what it means you should be the
president you should be the president of
the world the president of peace do you
know what a no-fly zone does it starts a
war how do you enforce a no-fly zone
okay russian migs come flying in and
you're like hey guys you can't fly there
no you have to send up planes to shoot
them down and like i've always said look
i don't believe that there's never an
appropriate time for where that's not
what i'm saying however you either are
all in or all out something does not sit
well with me when we are sending tens of
billions of dollars in aid to ukraine
well we're not in the war we just like
yes but you said look there's 14 billion
dollars that's ukraine's money now
it's for it's
long tables they need longer tables oh
where'd they get 14 billion i don't know
we're not touching you it's like come on
of course you're gonna piss him off he
took it out of my wallet i don't know
what he's gonna do with it yeah i have
no idea how they expect to um
[Applause]
what's that
uh we got some in the security feed oh
yeah
oh somebody's uh broken oh no it's a tip
what
oh he's still all right we do you should
really watch out come on oh almost like
we could have warned him
see there
just what's that what's going on
huh
oh here it comes all right
all right all right oh help whoa
oh
okay did you get it oh
i got him oh he's down
that's the fourth time this week piece
of cake
oh jeez oh don't worry he's still he's
still alive no he'll be he'll be fine
and by fine i mean he'll be dead uh by
the way walther official firearm sponsor
of a lot of crowder studios uh you can
go to waltherarms.com to shop online or
use the dealer locator to find what if
you want to buy a firearm and like i've
always said there are plenty of great
firearms out there just go to your local
gun range and try the walther run
walther
on walther review on google bing duck
duck wherever you want to use netscape
nav ask you can go ask jeeves
and you will see it's the best kept
secret in the firearm industry because
they don't have all these crazy large
shows that's that's nice oh this nice
one yeah yeah this is a well what's that
one called uh i don't know what it's oh
there's uh he's just he's can you shoot
him again no you know hey uh brendan
brennan come in here can you just clean
this up please
brandon you should be fine by now right
yeah he just got stabbed that's a while
ago okay he's fine he put a band-aid on
yeah brendan just if you don't mind just
cleaning no cleaning that up don't uh
get him out of here he's good
make sure there was no rust on that
blade though that can be a real mess
yeah exactly sometimes they've been
known to dip them in in manure so that
you get sep you might want to check
yourself for sepsis yeah yeah that's
true
pepsi but that's good to always get
checked for sure yeah the old tommy lee
knife yeah call it the old tommy lee
knifing trick that's what they call it
it's a trick as old as time yeah stab
you on a boat yep guys moaning was
annoying yeah it really was i
have a weird it's more of a nuisance
speaking of nuisance
i just watched this yesterday and i know
look i just go with me here on this
because i know a lot of people say well
who cares about john stewart i think jon
stewart is very talented i think he's
very funny i think when he's in
uh the room he's usually the sharpest
guy in the room just to be clear and
i've said that many times even though i
disagree with him politically but
yesterday this segment was uploaded
right here on youtube and for some
reason it keeps these things keep being
featured
in my feed
they're doing it on purpose um and it's
a segment called the human cost of
climate change now
i want to go through this piece by piece
because every single thing they say
is wrong and he's sitting down with i
would imagine supremely unqualified
writers or producers you'll see in a
second
who they haven't really even made it
through debate 101. honestly these
people would be
ill-equipped to sit down at a change my
mind table every point that they bring
up and they think is insightful
is the first point that someone would
bring up on a debate about climate
change before it's shut down and they
get to the secondary points that are
more effective however this is being
peddled to people who don't really pay
attention the left requires that you not
only be uninformed but typically that
you be misinformed as you will see here
in this segment and i'm not saying that
they're deliberately misinforming you
they themselves
are misinformed uh and let me know you
can comment below uh that's one of the
best things obviously for the youtube
algorithm but if you think that any of
these arguments are convincing from jon
stewart or his
writers
and
if you change your mind after this
segment okay let's go to their first
claim that they make which by the way
put this in your memory bank
because their final point
completely contradicts this point so
here we go it's generally not
the wealthy folks who are it's people
who are living in communities
on the pressure the people with the
least resources there's a big
discrepancy between who suffers and who
causes the suffering it's always been
the case in the world there are haves
and then there's a giant swath of
have-nots and for some reason this one
now we're all like i'm really concerned
about them but like i mean what's
different now is that climate change is
here for a lot of people who are
currently suffering but we all care
about it because they know it's coming
for them it'll eventually come for the
rich person
right yeah it'll eventually come he
looks worried for the rich person yeah
right yeah because it's the rich people
who are going to have to deal with gas
prices and inflation yeah with their
electric vehicles which you've
encouraged people to go out and buy
by the way which also has resulted in an
increase in prices which you then [ __ ]
about because you had to kick elon musk
out of california well he had to leave
california but effectively he was right
he was forced to leave because of your
green policies oh green policies can't
coexist with tesla
you know what affects the poor more i
don't know seven dollar gas crazy high
inflation and here's something that
people don't necessarily talk about a
whole lot not just in the united states
yeah now it's inconvenient in the united
states and this is i'm wanting to play
you know identity politics but i was at
the cancun climate summit years ago and
we went through this and uh we ran some
numbers but global skyrocketing energy
prices can actually be measured
in human lives just to be clear 2.3
million people 2.3 million people die
every year
worldwide because they don't have access
to safe clean energy in their homes so a
good example there is if there isn't
enough energy for uh electricity they
have to burn wood in their huts yeah and
they end up dying respiratory diseases
and guess what when the imf won't loan
your country money to build those coal
fired plants you basically go okay well
i guess we're just cutting wood down
again right and burning animal dung in
the tents so that we can cook food and
it's just not clean also when you hold a
climate summit in cancun you can tell
you really value it yes you very much
care about people yeah come on down
we're gonna drink giant margaritas right
well who does she think those people are
john kerry now this country aoc
everything that she's doing is making a
decision from the perspective of a rich
person who can afford nothing what's
ironic is she goes to she goes to
johnson says well rich i'm looking at
you like i am a rich person you are all
rich people if you understand the
concept of wealth globally so let me
give you kind of 30 grand and up yeah
the u.s uh is it gdp per capita i think
is the number that we have
per capita is 63 000
okay gas is currently 1.2 dollars a
liter and i'm using this so that we can
compare liters to liters uh zimbabwe gdp
per capita is 1200 that's less than 63
000. definitely gas prices there are 2.1
liters so uh 2.1 dollars per liter
that's
so do the math
do the math there what do you think
happens to someone who is making let's
say a thousand two thousand dollars a
year when gas prices go up to seven
eight nine dollars a gallon
and of course obviously we see a
correlation with all of their energy
costs yeah well
they die
and especially knowing what we know that
global uh global cooling is actually far
more deadly to the cost of human lives
if you actually look at the numbers
this is the we're doing this all in the
name of not seeing our world temperature
go up
1.6 degrees
per 100 years
but the people who are here right now
can't afford to live yeah especially the
developing world who didn't have the
opportunity that we had we had the
opportunity to go with the cleanest or
sorry the cheapest energy sources
possible and we've kind of made our way
up that ladder toward now we can afford
to do other things
we're just refusing to do the things
that are great but we can afford it they
can't and they're paying with their
lives because you want gas prices to be
artificially high so that people have to
switch to electric which is powered by
coal right
for the last two years it's been shut
down and everything in our society is
based on materialism
it's kind of difficult to keep up what
for oh okay i was confused
he pau it was a pregnant paul yes it was
a pregnant pause
and by the way you might want to take
another one of those uh pregnancy tests
i would oh geez because i don't know if
you know this but that actually means a
man if that stick turns pink you have
prostate cancer oh i've already used 11
sticks
well it's a lot of prostate cancer oh
it's malignant is what i mean to tell
you
so here's something else if enacted the
paris climate accord would not only
we'll go back to global but here it
would hurt average americans not the
policy makers so there'd be 400 000 job
losses oh gee 20 000 lost on average to
a family of four all references
available at lighterworthcrider.com
uh 2.5 trillion dollars
in aggregate gdp loss you'd see a 13 to
20 something percent increase in
electricity costs and by the way as
energy costs increase the risk of deaths
increase across the board in the 2000s
we saw decreases in energy prices uh
they saved 11 000 lives per year yeah
and those were just actually i think
winter deaths like you said the cold is
actually a much bigger problem than it
is in summer months but 11 000 a year
that's
that's this is a very common
this is a very common argument that they
want to make they talk about climate
justice
go speak with a black person in inner
city detroit tell them that your number
one goal on the agenda is climate
justice and they won't know what you're
talking about they'll look at you like
lobsters crawling out of your ears and
then when you tell them that in order to
uh basically establish some new form of
climate justice i don't know like a
five-page build yeah when you're talking
about detailed aoc's bill what was that
bill called again like the green new
deal yeah the green new deal
that's what it was called that's right i
just forgot about it because i took up
the first page yeah i had memorized they
used a very large font and also aoc
don't go with courier new triple spaced
with comic sans
tell us someone in inner city detroit
that by the way in order to uh to enact
climate justice uh gas prices and your
your energy prices your monthly bills
are gonna have to go up by 20 percent
watch them see how long it takes before
you wake up from your ass kicking
now here's another claim that they make
uh
well this is when they try and get a
little more pragmatic and of course this
also doesn't work everything they say
flies in the face of reality something
else i wanted you know the point that
you just made is an important point
about uh you know how they haven't been
able to use meaning the third world yeah
the kinds of energy that we have in the
united states it follows food it
actually follows sort of the
evolutionary chain of how humans have
consumed food right so we were primarily
nomadic then we had the agricultural
revolution and then that allowed us to
be more sedentary right we became more
agrarian societies where we had our own
plot of farmland then you had the
industrial revolution and then after
that things could be shipped right so
people now no longer had to have a farm
but they could have food in the
convenience of their own homes same
thing with energy you start off with
coal as filthy as can possibly be then
you have dirtier ways of extracting oil
it gets cleaner it gets cleaner you have
natural gas you have fracking you have
cleaner coal energy whereas these other
people they're still stuck in being
nomadic trucks quite literally by the
way in a lot of these countries they're
still nomadic by nature
let alone dealing with modern forms of
energy you think that you're going to go
to the hutu tribesmen
and the plains of whatever i don't
necessarily know where they live i'm not
a geopoliticist
i think you're gonna go to them and tell
them to buy an eevee
it's not gonna work where are you gonna
plug it in
tesla africa has not taken off quite as
well as they had hoped the amish used
more energy than people in the third
world across the globe you'd have better
luck telling an amish person to plug in
a tape recorder than telling people in
honduras to use an eevee
also that's in africa it's just an
elephant yeah it really is yeah you just
jump on its back and now we can't hunt
them for their tusks okay so yeah thanks
now my piano sucks yeah well it's a
keyboard really so yeah come on don't
try and oversell it it's a guitar don't
try and keep up appearances love let's
go to their next point which also makes
no sense and flies in the face of
reality the thing you said that i find
interesting is
fossil fuels those companies we can't
just view them as the enemy in this
crisis they are not just the villain
they make it but we use it like they
wouldn't make it if we didn't use it and
if we didn't need to use it like but
they could make other stuff that we
would just as easily use really they own
the present
and i don't think you can get them to
give up their piece of the present
unless you cut them in on the future
okay so a couple of points so they say
they could make other
they could create other forms of energy
that we could use and then he talks
about we need to cut them out on a piece
of the deal right the haves that have
nuts okay let's address the first part
since you're an energy expert uh like
what
sweetheart i hear this argument a lot
like oh well these fossil fuel companies
they could just create another form of
energy well it's like telling pepsi oh
they could make uh chip sets for
smartphones yeah but that's not what
they do yeah that's not what they do and
who are you to tell them what they
should do or what they are required to
do i know you want to enforce that
through the government with me by men
with guns while also robbing us of our
basic right to own firearms but like
what like what wind solar is this what
you're talking about
fossil fuel companies could go to winter
solar well it doesn't work
we have this this is we've already had
the petri dish germany we've used this
example before and unfortunately now
france is actually transitioning to
renewables why because of international
governing bodies that tell them that
they should move away from nuclear not
because it's better for the environment
so germany 55 point something percent of
their energy came from renewables the
references are available on the website
what do they have what were the results
more carbon emissions they had brownouts
that's where they would have to sell
their energy at a loss i believe they're
surpluses at a loss so they'd have
periods where they would have no energy
and then they have too much energy
because the battery technology isn't
there the storage capacity isn't there
now france's energy for a long time and
this is going to be decreasing was 76
percent nuclear yeah
they produced one tenth of the carbon
emissions that germany did for half the
price
for half the price some would say that's
a good thing yes it's better so less
waste and it's cheaper well her
suggestion is invent a whole new way to
have energy though no no no no that was
the head writer dave who said they could
make other things that we could use just
as easily right i'm quoting the head
writer correct cause that's what it said
below her and i'm like list them and
that's not true hey she has peaches on
her sweatshirt all right all right well
i'm just i'm on the peaches i have a
problem with what comes out of her mouth
yeah it's just dumb i don't understand
it's not you rome wasn't built in a day
and i think we're doing pretty good
considering what does this it'll take
some time oh yeah and people who are
poor can't afford that car also thank
you for the rome reference because i can
segue to aqua ducks which brings us to
hydroelectric by the way i'm from canada
that's a stretch i'm from quebec shut up
i'm from quebec
it's perfectly appropriate our bill was
our our electric bill was hide our hydro
bill which would confuse people who
would come to like a hydro bill what do
you mean your your water bottle no
because a huge portion of our electric
power came from hydroelectricity that's
something that everyone should it's
basically swiss family robinson right
you have some running water okay you
capture it and by the way that second
third generation is going to be a bunch
of inbred morons i don't know how people
watch swiss family robinson are not just
weep for the future but hydropower can
we do that oh no wait the left here not
only do they not want nuclear they don't
want hydro power because we can't build
dams in california you can't build dams
because of a fish that can't even swim
well the smelt damn damn damn
well okay nuclear this is a perfect
example it's been vilified it has the
lowest amount of deaths per kilowatt
hour it's not even close it it's
basically carbon emission free oh no
wait the left is opposed to that as well
so we can't do hydropower we can't do
nuclear that's not allowed so
wind and solar it doesn't work and by
the way the reason that certain solar
panels weren't allowed to be put up in
california is because of an endangered
species of bug and turtle if you can't
do it in the desert in inland california
you can't do solar it's not going to
work hey by the way you know who thinks
we should be doing more nuclear
the guy selling the evs yes elon musk
said europe should be going back to this
so that guess what russia can't cut you
off from energy hey that might stop a
war who knew oh and then they say he's a
he's a puppet for putin oh he's a shill
of course he gave startling to ukraine
guys do you remember that do you
remember that so that's the they can
create other forms of energy okay well
okay we're done with that guy now they
move on to greedy companies right these
greedy companies who aren't going to
give up this power right that we need to
cut them in on a piece of the future
this is also something that people don't
understand
um it's similar to when people say big
pharma doesn't want you to know about
like vitamins supplements and nutrition
there's some truth to that but if you
also look at some of the biggest
supplement companies in the world some
of them are basically co-owned by big
pharmaceutical companies they stand to
make the most money some of the time so
let's look at some of these companies
blackrock right blackrock who they have
huge stakes in energy companies and you
also look at the relationships that
companies like blackrock again too big
to fail
uh and what kind of relationship they
have with energy companies blackrock is
punishing companies over climate and
action one of the biggest companies in
the history of mankind they're punishing
people over climate and action but to go
back to the point about uh how climate
change hurts the most vulnerable among
us right hurts the poorest among us
because that's what they need to push
their social agenda of a green new deal
and climate justice well okay what about
this black rock ceo larry fink this
wasn't that long ago
was basically saying you know what we're
going to have to have a few years of
discomfort uh in order to transition
away from fossil fuels so big greedy
company who you're saying hey we need to
cut them in on the future like you have
some kind of a crystal like like you
really understand the art of the deal
after just saying that these energy
companies can just i don't know create
new forms of energy
uh
you fail to see the connection that
these are the people who have the
largest vested interest in punishing
companies as part of this global social
agenda here's larry fink ceo of
blackrock himself don't take my word for
it we are going to find new supplies of
oil elsewhere maybe opec will begin to
raise their production the u.s will
re-begin to invest again back into our
our in our energy fields
high energy prices is going to
accelerate decarbonization people more
and more people say i can't afford gas
i'm going to buy an ev so we're going to
see behavior changes and over the time
the next three or four years we are
going to see less dependencies which is
really good for the world we're going to
have a better mix of energy between
hydrocarbons and renewables and
so it's about a two to three year
possible uncertainty but i actually love
where we're going oh but it's wonderful
because it's good for you
just like the housing market as you guys
buy them all up at 180. people can't
afford gas they're going to buy an ev
it's the dumbest sentence i've ever
elevated for a long time until we
we have these corrections
he loves the direction it's going keep
in mind that's the guy who's a ceo of
the company who's bought up
a large portion of housing here in the
united states largely you know single
income family type housing so that we
can create a permanent class of renters
you won't be the same guy when you [ __ ]
about well and of course you want the
government to come in and solve the
problem just like you want the
government to come in and solve the
problem of energy and by the way the
government is the same entity that
declared blackrock too big to fail you
can thank elizabeth warren for that or
at least they want to i don't know if
that's officially been passed yet but
that was a proposal uh
do you see the cozy relationship here
hey you can't afford a home why
blackrock governments in bed with
blackrock hey you can't afford gas ceo
of blackrock says that's a great thing i
love the direction we're going
government's in bed with blackrock do
you see again you're talking about
greedy companies and i don't disagree
but that's not free market capitalism
that's not even crony capitalism
that's just bordering on socialism when
you understand the relationship between
blackrock and also by the way a lot of
these big tech companies and our federal
government which brings us to the next
point and this is a point that they make
all this is all in one video this is all
in one five minute video and it was like
wave after wave of [ __ ] where i
can't believe they fit all of these
straw man arguments into one five-minute
segment and no one said hey hold on a
second we shouldn't upload this wait why
because it's all
incorrect
how'd you find that out i spent ten
minutes on bing
i spent five minutes with that bent back
paper clip
telling me that i didn't know how to
spell hippopotamus
that was my fact check that everything
here is wrong mrs head writer okay so
here they talk about and you hear this
all the time that we subsidize fossil
fuels more than that's the reason that
we haven't transitioned to green energy
it's wrong but
hear it from them first greedy companies
aren't going to make decisions based on
morality to that point though so it's
like even if you cut them in yeah i'm
curious what cutting them in looks like
in a perfect world because we already
subsidized them with very little
regulation very little you know they're
already being given money but not for
renewables right it's less for much much
much less for renewables and you
uploaded that [ __ ]
i can't believe he showed us who writes
his show yeah i can't believe that he
showed us his head writer was a white
person i know oh that's terrible
answerable couldn't get tom brady on the
payroll huh yeah oh jesus come on i see
an empty kaepernick seat by the writer's
table
jon stewart somebody could take a knee
right next to that table one person of
color and she's not said a word thus far
well she did she said two words but they
were wrong oh that's true so this is
something they say oh they receive well
first off
subsidies through what through uh
relaxed regulation ah very little
regulation energy companies i don't
think you can find a more regulated
industry no in the industrialized world
outside of maybe health insurance
companies
maybe airlines and by the way these
always rate very highly on the
favorability scale right you guys love
energy companies health insurance
companies and airlines those are those
are the top three
oh my gosh on the tip sheet so this is
factually incorrect we give far
far more
in subsidies to renewable energy
than fossil fuel companies let me give
you some numbers really quick in 2016
overall energy subsidies
to the entire energy sector coal 19
million directly 1.2 billion overall
natural gas 111 million dollars directly
negative
773 million overall because of the tax
expenditures which were 940 million
dollars oops nuclear 365 million dollars
overall renewables
it's ironic they don't consider they
don't put nuclear really in that
category right um especially when you
understand what you can also do with
nuclear waste as well and that off
that's sort of what they use to cool it
down that heat can also be recycled as
energy this is modern technology that of
course because of regulations we can't
utilize but 365 million to nuclear
overall renewables
909 million directly
6.6 billion dollars overall so they want
you to believe that fossil fuel natural
gas right that they're receiving more in
subsidies than renewables
negative 773 million
versus a positive of 6.6
billion
it's not even close it's even
exacerbated by the fact that in 2016
we're talking about this very same year
renewables only generated 15
of total electricity created the rest
was fossil fuels nuclear again and at
what cost
right so every time you get a you know
an electric bill or a plan they're like
hey sign up for this green thing i'm
like oh well that's cool what is it
going to cost well about 25 to 35
percent more right in your current place
that's just my experience i mean maybe
higher in california because they don't
have any regulations remember that
what's it going to cost uh 65 species of
endangered birds which ones can you can
you name them because i don't like all
birds yeah well birds are weird not all
birds matter steve we can live without
gas guys we can't live without them
turtles right
where the cartel is going to fit their
heads what else snap at us when we try
to feed it why don't we let animals die
that are supposed to yeah sharks
that's what we do with the canadian
geese and now they're just everywhere
and i wish they were dead they almost
took down an airplane thank god yes
sully sullenberg well that's also
because of rich white people of course
uh for example in wyoming in these
states now they have a problem with
grizzly bears and uh they're not allowed
to hunt them well you can you can they
said well we'll do we'll help keep
grizzly bears in check right oh okay so
we can hunt them yeah for i think it's a
two hundred thousand dollar tag oh jeez
maybe it's a three hundred thousand
somewhere between two hundred and four
hundred thousand dollar tag mortgage
grizzly bear so who does it it ends up
being a bunch of wealthy people and then
of course the poor people just get you
know murdered by bears yeah it's not
murder it's just it's the circle of life
remember in michigan the wolf hunt vote
for the u.p yes and then it got voted
down by a bunch of hipsters in flint and
detroit it's like you guys you guys you
shouldn't have a say
in what they do up there
like well if you hunt the wolves they
don't take out the coyotes they said
yeah well we're not so concerned about
the coyote problem as we are the wolf
problem yeah the coyotes are skittish
yeah the wolf's like you're mine yeah do
you know exactly you know in napa valley
that if a wolf goes on a shirt in
michigan yes if this year is eating your
crop napa valley's known for wine the
world over huge huge money for
if a deer is eating your grapes you
can't shoot it
this is the same kind of thinking like
when there really is a problem because
it takes out their the whole thing that
they're producing well you can't shoot
it but uh there is the run it over with
your tractor loophole oh well tons of
people who shoot it and never act like
it never happened you just hide the body
in the cayman islands okay you can give
it a colombian necktie yes
i'm partial to the peruvian bambi
you're going to wish the worst thing
that happened to you was your mom being
shot
but touching my weight
these were my franzia grapes
thumper says hello all right
here's the next comment that they make
which doesn't necessarily need to be
rebutted but i'm going to do it anyway
uh because in order to try and make this
case of well riddled with now i don't
want to say riddled
exclusively based on factual
inaccuracies
not so exclusively
all the substantiation in this video is
factually inaccurate every single claim
that they make and they're not
and that's really difficult to do
because they're trying to evade making
factual statements because they don't
necessarily want to be held accountable
which brings us to our next point
well this is all the problem of uh
something something something
corporations corporations are sociopaths
right so they're also not going to do
better out of the good of their own
hearts right but you need accountability
goodness how do you hold them
accountable for
if we cut them in where does
accountability live in that so i think
you have a political problem here
because because they control so much
that is the engine of our economy same
with the financial markets
they have politicians over a barrel
interesting okay so corporations are
sociopaths now far be it for me to
disagree and this is the issue that i've
talked about in the past where
does your worldview require
inconsistency i believe for example that
that ceo of blackrock saying that he
loves the direction of skyrocketing
energy costs i believe he might be a
sociopath at the very least selfish i
believe that power corrupts i believe
that can take place with powerful
companies in the free market but you
know who else i think
often lean towards being being uh
sociopathic and uh in nature career
politicians and to repeat your question
how do you hold them accountable when
they can just write new laws so that
they are never held accountable
i mean at least with the company now
let's not talk about the the socialist
companies and what i mean by that is
deemed too big to fail like the uh what
the financial institutions you just
bitched about or the airlines that you
guys all [ __ ] about right i'm talking
about the mom and pop shops and by the
way mom and pop shops can include
businesses that are worth 50 100 200
million we're just talking about
companies that operate on an honest
profit margin and don't receive
subsidies those are the companies that
i'm talking about here
they break the law guess what they pay a
price what do you do
when you have career politicians
who are not beholden at all not only to
laws but by the way if that mom and pop
shop creates a product that sucks
or there's a scandal
their customer base turns against them
guess what that's some level of
accountability so we have two levels of
accountability for the private sector
for these businesses again we're not
talking about the crony socialist
businesses who receive never-ending
bailouts and are deemed too big to fail
what do they have they're subject to
laws and they are subject to market
forces in that they cannot force you to
purchase their services it has to be a
voluntary exchange of goods those two
safeguards do not exist
for career politicians so if one is a
sociopath you at least can keep them in
check
somehow
somewhat there's a hope
if a career politician is a sociopath
you can you have no hope there is
nothing you can do because well you know
we'll just write a new law so that uh
that doesn't really matter kind of like
when nancy pelosi i don't know if you
remember this defended inside insider
trading
martha stewart was wearing an orange
jumpsuit yes
for doing what nancy pelosi here
flagrantly defends just sign a new law
that defends it madam speaker uh insider
just completed a five-month
investigation finding that 49 members of
congress and 182 senior congressional
staffers have violated the stock act um
the insider training law i'm wondering
if you have any reaction to that and
secondly should members of congress and
their spouses be banned from trading
individual stocks the answer is yes just
say yes no to this second one um wrong
any we have a responsibility to report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five month
review but if
people aren't reporting they should be
you're very familiar
because this is a free market in people
oh
we have seen a lot of free markets they
should be able to participate in that
now you love the free market miss we
have to pass the bill to know what's in
it i i'm a little confused it's it's
only a free market if everybody's
playing kind of with the same roughly
because it's impossible the same
information you're you're literally
going
yeah we're going to approve this one so
go buy that stock today because we're
going to approve that tomorrow in
committee and that'll get out and that
that's going to make a millions of
dollars and so that's fair yeah for
people who don't understand what this
because people often throw out the
talking point inside our trading laws
with people uh who are you know in
elected office let me break it down for
really quickly it's illegal for example
if you're in the private sector for
someone to give you a tip saying hey i
work over here at pepsi right and
company and we're gonna or coke and they
say hey by the way we're gonna be
releasing new coke tomorrow so you might
want to invest in it which by the way
don't get tips from a guy who works at
new coke ford etzel people yeah exactly
right that's illegal if you invest you
make a bunch of money however it's not
illegal for nancy pelosi to say oh you
know what we're actually going to
approve this bill that allows these
solar panels in i don't know the mojave
desert oh and by the way we're going to
give a no-bid contract to this company
to make those panels and let me invest
in some stock for said company now it's
estimated that pelosi herself owns about
46 million dollars in stocks and guess
what her husband does he runs a venture
capital fund how convenient you do that
and they would have you and they would
have you in solitary confinement with
lines on the wall like zorro yeah and
let's just bring it down to a practical
example from the last couple of years
we're about to close down the entire
economy we are about to close everything
down and i'm gonna buy some amazon stock
because that's they had that information
before we did obviously right right so
then they so you think that's fair i'm
gonna close everything down i'm gonna go
buy amazon stock right that's not fair
it has to be public information well
it's it's i would say it should be
illegal
not according to taking a risk here uh
and here's their final claim that they
make and again remember that first point
that they made jon stewart the head
writers i don't remember all of their
names i'm horrible with names and it's
even exacerbated by the fact that i
don't care about these people so
the first point was it's not going to
affect you know the rich eventually
it'll come for the rich but right now it
affects the poorest among us that's we
have to act on climate change now so
that we help the impoverished and the
underprivileged that was their first
point well now they end it with
actually we're gonna have to destroy
their lives because something's
something something justice one of you
know the conversations about climate
change is that we have to have a just
transition that
people you know coal mining jobs are
actually good-paying jobs we hear that a
lot progress has is never fair
and almost never just
and i feel i i think i my view of the
world is more like how can we give the
soft landings to the
inevitable
destruction
that is ancillary to our
progress
and there it is
your jobs your livelihoods
are ancillary to our progress see what
now keep in mind they said ancillary
which means uh insignificant right
separated from
to our progress is there any more
elitist phrase that you've ever heard on
a program there are jobs and livelihoods
which will be painful but ancillary to
our progress meaning the progress of
people like jon stewart and those head
writers of people in california the
elites in new york uh in the new yorks
of the world the californians of the
world and your
livelihood is ancillary you know what
else is
well the cost of of gas let's what's
under answer let's look at that the cost
of gas
the cost of all energy the cost to heat
your homes your jobs right if you're
working in any kind of an energy sector
that isn't renewable hey you know what
else is ancillary because we want to cut
them in a piece of the future places
like blackrock your ability to own a
home
so right now we have a bunch of
privileged wealthy people game planning
the entire economy under the guise of
climate justice while considering
your livelihood
and everything they're in to be
ancillary there's no conspiracy that my
friends is the great reset that's the
great reset that's what it is that's why
blackrock ceo loves the direction we're
going
with the the the pain the discomfort of
energy cost he's not affected nor is
john store we know stephen colbert isn't
affected he would pay 15
a gallon you're just ancillary to that
room to those boards and those
sociopaths and government you don't need
a conspiracy
that's the great reset all right any
other any other points you guys want i i
just i want to
i hope that show gets better because jon
stewart's better than that i don't he's
surrounded i don't know if that's the
show or behind the scenes is that the
show
i think behind the scenes for the show
but if that's any indication of what the
show is like yeah he's starting out with
bad information
better people around him you're right
though it's always a savior complex yeah
and it's the rich saying how here's the
problem every rich person is an evil and
every poor person isn't great right and
that seems to be this constant narrative
that they put out there they're trying
to save the other person right and there
are people like i do think that um jon
stewart actually cares about people i do
think he genuinely does and i do think
that the ceo of blackrock who looks like
mr burns crosswith smithers is probably
a pretty evil dude yeah you know like
that's a good example of it but doing
all this and trying to push this
narrative isn't helping anybody it's
it's never it's never gonna like he
doesn't
when you're talking about the rich and
you're not aware of the fact that you
are the rich yeah that's when it looks
bad well he kind of acknowledges that in
in that segment
but the rest of the table yeah the rest
of them don't realize him but yeah the
table for crying out loud do you know
how much she dances like a gopher when
she hears about burn victims yes i know
so
she loves jesus right do you know how i
know they're rich at that table by
global standards
clean water obesity oh well yeah not all
the writers
by the way we do have plus size clothing
at crowdershop.com so if you guys want
to support this program we do not
receive
millions of dollars in funding from
apple but we do have
xxl clothing i believe though of course
quantities are limited because you know
and there's an extra chance you should
come and see stephen and i when you buy
three seats yes exactly
we're playing classic peter we love you
and smash the like button right now
because we're going to move on to a
segment here about which i know very
little
it's okay i got your back but that's
because gerald uh he likes wearing other
men's names on his back i've never done
that and apparently he actually has been
pinned with tom brady's high school ring
it's time for gerald no sports
[Applause]
[Music]
let me just set this up before i uh what
is it do i before i hut to you what is
that called handoff to you maybe a
handoff or a pass a hut a hut how dare
you good
you're offending so many people i don't
know but either way someone's wearing a
cancer ribbon so
before we go to tom brady i don't know
if you've probably been hearing in the
news that uh colin kaepernick he you
know released a training video because
he wants to he's hoping he's vying for
an audition for a chance at slavery
he's in the he's in the freak show
audition phase of american idol for
slavery right it's exciting yeah he
actually tweeted out i've been i've been
prepping for the last four years i've
been throwing to a bunch of friends uh
and i'm ready i'm ready to have some
real receivers where are you guys at
yeah like to go and throw to one that's
dogging your friends that apparently
you've been throwing to which maybe
that's appropriate but two like you've
been out of the league for four years
and you sucked to the last two and a
half that you were in the league and
you're getting better yeah you were a
grand disappointment yes
just as a player you got beat out by
blaine gabbert i remember uh think about
that but i remember that in roots i
remember the uh
the freed blacks trying to get into the
cotton fields oh that's true yeah they
were they were sending in mixed tapes
there was there's quite a combine to try
to get in there sir yeah please sir i
want to i want to work for you i want
the signing bonus sir signing bonus i
love that it's like bidding just like
slavery it's like right except for the
slave gets all the money yeah yeah and
right now you are demanding
it's an injustice what you it's an
injustice when you work for the nfl
because you're a slave and it's an
injustice when you're not rehired by the
nfl because they're not allowing you to
be a slave do you see why that guy was
crappy for the locker room yeah well
there's also difference between being
fired and retiring yes that's true
exactly
backing your toys and going home it's
just george costanza showing up back at
the office like i still work here right
right you know colin you don't yeah oh
that whole thing when i left for two and
a half years come
on guys
you called me a racist someone threw a
brick through my wife's window
oh come on water under the bridge i mean
admit i was basically a slave like come
on i made those commercials remember i
got the nike contract for kneeling after
i got my uh my perm yeah
my parents are white stop showing photos
of it stop showing photos i go to the
same hairdresser as rachel dolezal and
sean king
but of course we're going to give you
the top five reasons why tom brady needs
to be uh canceled oh because tom brady
you were saying this this was announced
this week he's yeah he's coming back
right so i think he was retired for you
know just a couple of months and so on
sunday he's he sent out this this post
and said he's coming back after you know
he's going to be playing his 23rd season
i don't think this guy is a real human
being at this point yeah but a great
quarterback right so yeah i don't know
how he has the energy after yeah
supermodel well that's weird 61 years
old
apparently he doesn't have enough money
okay well he's probably just sitting
around going i'm tom brady why am i at
home making eggos yeah he's just looking
at a supermodel wife oh gross
look at her one more time basically i'm
so tired of hitting that
so just
like can you come and make love to me ah
she's exhausting gosh what is this two a
days all right i'm gonna go i'm gonna
toss on some wrangler jeans and go back
to work
we have actually i think there's a clip
of him uh returning unretiring
tom brady will be back there at
quarterback retirement that lasted all
of 40 days he's going to return to the
buck for a 23rd nfl season he'll start
at quarterback at the age of 45 for
tampa bay after leading the nfl in
passing yards touchdowns completions and
attempts last season the greatest of all
time
has come back after a 40-day high that
guy's like 90s 40-day trip with life as
a retired human tom brady has decided
get me the [ __ ] back into some sort of
i had a wonderful weekend and my
goodness who do we have here
thomas edward patrick brady jr
is back your worst nightmare is back
you're going to have a long season next
year this is what passes for media and
sports uh it's the worst the best show
ever
to celebrate i love how they always just
fit a woman in there and give her some
you know she's probably about as
prepared as jon stewart is to discuss
climate change yes yeah wow
you could be a fan the greatest of the
greats at the round table in sports
media like when people say no vagina no
opinion on any issue you know abortion
pregnancy contraception it's like yeah
well when was the last time you played
football get the hell off sportscenter
well uh look tom brady did take to
twitter to announce uh his unretiring
and so i'll read some of his okay go
ahead his words these past few months
i've realized my place is still on the
field and not in the stands because you
were gonna go to the games that time
will come back and if it was going to go
to the game it would be the stand the
box opposed to the most privileged
executive box that ever existed we're
supposed to believe he's in the
nosebleed section next to the cunon
shaman true uh i love my teammates and i
love my supportive family they make it
all possible i'm coming back for my 23rd
season in tampa
unfinished business and then he says
something that i can't say
lfg it's let f go you can fill in the f
and uh i think he's excited right fudge
no david is not the fudge now look it
would seem like everybody's going to be
excited moratorium on stelter talk yes
oh dead it seemed that everybody's going
to be excited that tom brady is going to
return but really the question is should
they that's odd
and i know people think that brady is
the goat right the greatest of all time
uh but really here's the stupid thing
about that acronym
you just said the acronym and then said
what the acronym meant there's no point
to the acronym anymore well it's like a
goat greatest of all time well then why
say goat i just didn't want to sound
like you know some some people don't
know just say one or the other it was
for you do you know what goat is yes i
do well then i'm sorry but the point is
if i didn't it wouldn't help me to say
go you just seem elitist
by now you shouldn't even be watching
anything you're an idiot also let's be
careful with saying go too many times i
don't know if that terrorist from
earlier is dead yet that's true he may
come running we don't need an aroused
semi-dead terrorist blood will be
flowing just not to the right yes no i
hope there's not enough blood left so
this brings us to i guess first off i
don't know why he unretired but uh the
top five reasons i guess to cancel tom
brady right that's the only way you're
gonna stop this man i do hope it's
comically his worst season ever yes
well look just not that i don't like him
it's just out of humor yeah no of course
the nfl has been telling us and making
it very clear the kind of player that
they are looking for this balanced
individual and i don't i don't know that
tom brady fits this and so point number
one is just that he is a white cis male
yeah i don't know why they even allow
him back i mean he couldn't even make it
past the first round in uh john stuart
writer's room no that's true
cheerleading maybe that guy guys it's
gross yeah he's just so white good like
i mean this uh i can't believe it they
constantly give them chances while
they're blackballing
once in a generation talents like colin
yeah colin kaepernick guys they give
huge opportunities to that spit in their
face right and i don't know that we can
use doesn't mean you stop trying no term
anymore but uh i mean i think that's
insensitive according to the nfl so i
can't believe sis that's a word talking
about goat shouldn't be a word exactly
cis oh you mean normal yeah you mean
all right look no look there are there
are other reasons right so our second
reason uh on our list of five is that he
embodies this pull yourself up by your
bootstraps mentality that is just so
outdated right it is yes we can't expect
people they use it now they're going i
know we're supposed to pull our cell
phone player bootstraps yes even though
you say it with an eye roll it doesn't
mean that it's incorrect yes and we all
remember like tom brady tesla this this
over privileged guy was drafted 199th in
this in 2000 in the nfl draft out of the
university of michigan which sucks and
he looks like this let me see him oh
gosh i mean look at him and he ran a
five two five forty yards he looks like
he would be in he would be one of the uh
like the nude images when you're a kid
in biology class like it needs to be
someone who's not so ugly they're
off-putting but certainly not attractive
so it's pornography i'll be honest i
looks better than him in high school
yeah well look let's look at what a
5-2-5 40-yard dash actually looks
like i think joe biden outran him here
i saw a fat kid yesterday run faster
chasing the ice cream truck oh for sure
that was me and then i saw the pedophile
driving the truck run faster away from
the cops that's true
that was me at 207 pounds i ran about a
five flat which is not fast but i was
going to say before the knee injury i
guarantee you i could before my multiple
knee surgeries guarantee you everybody
would run faster well listen look
without one government subsidy like
we're talking about or any kind of a
handout he actually went on to win seven
super bowls again just because he's this
white privilege pull yourself up by your
bootstraps kind of guy right and here's
the thing too i will say about i don't
know a lot about football but i do know
he's obviously the best quarterback of
all time yeah joe montana no look
objectively you would have to list him
that way yeah but this is kind of a
perfect example sometimes the the people
who are best at something
make the worst coaches or they're not
the most effective coaches because
some people are just born with an innate
ability it's what we actually people use
the term talent sometimes and they
misuse the word talent yeah uh there are
some people who have something you can't
teach so tom brady from what i
understand obviously not a great runner
decent enough decent enough passer but
not the best in the league from what i
understand not the best not a bad arm
not very best but yeah he's not the best
he's good but he's not the best at any
one thing and it's very comparable to
the canadian in me you know wayne
gretzky wayne gretzky is the greatest of
all time you know in hockey and the
thing is wayne gretzky wasn't the best
at any one thing he wasn't the best
shooter you'd have to have someone like
a brett hall or something like that at
that point wasn't the best handler that
was mario lemieux that was a great
goalie not a great goalie uh not a great
uh not the best skater you'd have like a
mike madonna there but yeah there was
something about wayne gretzky and his
quote was don't go where the puck is go
where the puck's going to be it's like
well that's horrible coaching through
like oh so i just need to look in my
plasma ball uh yeah wayne gretzky thanks
for that advice but it was like the puck
was magnetized to his stick
he was just able to be where he needed
to be and he wasn't able to impart that
to someone else it seems like with tom
brady i mean his training is terrible
but he's very disciplined about his diet
about his sleep about his training and
there's something that it's just i don't
know if you would call it sports iq and
i think that's why so many people
dislike him because it's like he
shouldn't be as good as he is but he's
unbelievable but you're trying to
explain a talent to another person right
like that's just something that you have
and that's the way that his brain works
if yours doesn't function like that you
can't learn that well right it's a guy
and that's another problem that we have
with tom brady because tom brady point
number three is he's a winner cancel
this one right i can't believe what
look the nfl doesn't value any of these
things okay and so tom brady cannot be
the best ever like we just mentioned
seven super bowls three mvps he has the
records for most passing yards that's
not fair in a league that's largely
black well and he's firmly on the bottom
of the victim hierarchy and we know that
means he's a really really well yeah
that's not fair you got to give those
records pass them around some of the
black guys well that that's right
passing around 340 pound o-linemen they
have a life expectancy of 42.
yeah why isn't it holding on to his
records yeah
i mean he should look there's no i in
team guys right
well
and it also would explain his wonderful
career there's an eminent ent team
though so i mean there's a what an
eminent e i don't know how to spell it
team can be about me
i guess that is about me okay but you
know what if you rearrange if we're
playing for playing word jumble the
point is he's racist and he shouldn't be
allowed back in right the record don't
allow cal and kaepernick by the hair of
their chinny chin chin somebody which is
also to rub salt on the wound because
kaepernick can't grow a beard well
here's the other problem speaking of of
kaepernick uh actually uh tom brady is
actually a family man as well well sonic
this day just keeps getting worse
he has a healthy marriage uh to a
supermodel uh wife by the way her name
is it was a joke okay this is not very
black lives matter marxist not one of
those children
is trans no he has three heteronormative
kids and so i i just don't understand
how the nfl could let him come back into
the are we allow we're not allowed to
call for uh the killing of someone but i
think you two make an exception for tom
brady i would well if they didn't before
they might now after this this is my
final point and this really drives it
all american family man tom brady voted
for donald trump oh and he might have
done it twice i thought you were going
to say he had a white picket fence in
which case i would still also call for
the assassination yeah trump twice well
he actually has a long time friendship
with this mr donald trump who's been
kicked off appropriately from every
platform yeah appropriately from the
twitter right exactly uh and he's even
endorsed him in 2015 when donald trump
was running for president tom brady
endorsed donald trump yeah and someone
took him back they they did uh and we
actually we actually have a have a clip
here oh of the french tom brady
great guy great
great guy great friend of mine great
great champion unbelievable winner
[Applause]
he called today
and he said donald
i support you you're my friend
and i voted for
you boom
more like tom shady yeah am i right yeah
gosh yeah yeah i said it well he's
definitely said now but look if that's
not bad enough uh he even had a maga hat
in his locker what what did they find
what does he think he is there yeah it's
meg what is it let's take a picture like
it's a
elo of coke you took that
right yeah someone leaked it oh look at
these steroids yeah yeah look there's
another waiting through like get those
syringes out of here i gotta what is it
that's that hat yeah what was it yeah in
that locker room yeah you're just
stepping
there's no way that this guy should be
allowed i mean
one of the reasons he had to go down to
florida to finish his stellar career and
take all of his super bowl potential
with him is because he was in new
england he lives somewhere warm year
round yeah well i just hate him plays on
a you know what i bet you i bet you took
his supermodel wife too where she gets
like she gets to wear a bikini all the
time yeah yeah probably you know just
it's just enough gross it's too much
yeah what do you get everything yeah
it's too much tom brady and here's the
thing
he's obviously because in sports it's
somewhat of a meritocracy so you know he
gets to come back but guess what if
there was a writer as good as tom brady
who existed right the best right in the
face he still wouldn't make it into the
john stewart's
writer's room and that is at least even
though i don't know sports that well
that's at least one of the saving graces
of sports particularly combat sports all
right gerald you know sports
[Applause]
[Music]
send your tweets at g morgan jr also
feel free to photoshop his white board
from yesterday no you can comment below
we're going to play pokemon or racial
slur on mug club which in no way could
we ever play on youtube by the way
please no one actually uh go out and
kill tom brady okay that's not a i don't
want you to i'm just i'm just saying we
we all feel it but it's wrong to hate uh
youtube piss off
you